the heart doesn't show
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
this moment
[Music]
you're always on the run now
i think you're headed for
you really don't remember
[Music]
all the voices
[Music]
don't you think
[Music]
you don't have to answer
[Music]
i think
[Music]
but you really don't remember
[Music]
how's it going go down
when you're married
don't believe it's coming back soon
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i think got the aliens
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it ain't me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
look at me
[Music]
he's a muscles man
[Music]
hey
i got
hey
please love to breathe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
he's
you can best believe that he's a macho
man
he likes to be the leader he never
[Music]
uh
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
is
[Music]
hey
but she was more like a beauty queen
from a movie
is
[Music]
who would dance
[Music]
[Music]
who you love me
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
45th
president of the united states donald j
[Music]
trump
we're at least i know i'm free
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that right to me and i gladly
stand up
next to you and defend her still today
cause there ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless the usa
[Music]
from the lakes of minnesota
to the hills of tennessee
across the plains of texas
from sea to shining sea
from detroit down to houston
and new york to verily
where there's pride in every american
heart
and it's time we stand and say
[Music]
that i'm proud to be an american
where it is i know i'm free
and i won't forget the men who died
who gave that life to me and i've had
this end up
next to you and defend her still today
but there ain't no doubt i love this
[Music]
land
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
next to you and defend her still today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh hello jacksonville we love
jacksonville
i love jacksonville i'm thrilled to be
back
in my home state of florida with
thousands of loyal
hard-working american patriots this is
some proud uh
i just wish the cameras would show the
crowd they don't want to do that
they don't like to do that you know
it's harder for us to win because we
have a fake news back there but
but somehow we just keep on doing it
isn't it crazy
isn't it crazy this is some you know
it's interesting when biden comes to
florida have like 12
13 people you know they do this
and he has a hard time filling up the
circles here we probably have 30
000 people or something that's a lot of
people
well i want to thank you 40 days from
now we're going to
win florida we're going to win four more
years in the white house
and this is the most important election
in the history of our country i believe
that
it is because we're dealing with people
that are crazy
they're going to raise your taxes
they're going to take away your second
amendment you know that
your second amendment's not going
anywhere with me i can tell you
the democrat party has been completely
taken over by socialist marxists and far
left
extremists they embrace the policies of
communist cuba
socialist venezuela they want to end the
american dream for
hispanic americans we love hispanic
americans well
did you see they released the poll today
they said trump's doing really well
with the what's going on with the
hispanic it took you so long to figure
out that i love you
how long did it take no more of that
stuff
no the hispanic americans are great and
you know they did they released the poll
today and nobody's ever seen anything
like it
the republicans are beating the
democrats with hispanic americans think
of it
[Music]
no we're doing great we're doing great
and uh
they never like to show those balls
whenever you see they don't show too
many polls that's only because we're
winning we're winning by a lot
we think we're winning by like a lot
but the only poll that counts is on
november 3rd right that's the only poll
to counsel
[Applause]
so get out there don't let them bluff
you whatever it is get out there and
vote the republican party
is the party of job safety and freedom
and we will
ensure that america never becomes
a socialist or communist country
i've added that recently i said
socialist country i said now
a socialist or communist cut because
these people are crazy
kamala you know kamala is further left
than bernie i didn't know that
she is the furthest left in the u.s
senate
she was up at 15 when she started you
know that right that story
she went down to 14. then she went to 12
then she went to 11.
she went to nine and eight six
four two one
and then she left before i were the
great state of iowa where i made
ethanol possible for them ethanol
and i gave our farmers 28 billion
dollars thank you very much
china we took it out of china because
they were targeting
iowa and nebraska a lot of our great
states wisconsin
we gave our farmers a lot of money some
came down to farmers down in florida
they don't know that we got a lot of
farmers in florida
but here's the choice facing every
florida vote
joe biden will deliver a crippling
shutdown he's actually thinking about
can you no we did that and we saved
millions of lives that's it we're doing
good now and by the way your governor's
done a great job
florida is down low now in the
china virus it's china by the way
some people call it coronavirus that
sounds like a beautiful place in italy
right
no no it didn't come from italy it came
from china
but this guy's talking he'll shut it
down and be scientists so shut it down
and shut it down no we're not shutting
anything down
we are doing so well you look at our
numbers well you see the third quarter i
shouldn't say it because back there
but when you see how good the third
quarter is going to be and it comes out
just before the election so i'm taking a
risk when i say it
you won't believe the numbers you say i
tell you you're gonna see numbers
nobody's gonna believe those numbers
we're hearing from 25
to a 35 gdp nobody's ever heard of that
well iran has a 25 gdp too but it's a
negative gdp of 25.
they just announced negative 25. uh they
don't like me too much be careful be
careful i'm delivering a safe vaccine
and we're doing a record recovery this
recovery is a record they've never seen
anything like it
and next year is going to be i think the
best economic year in the history of our
country
[Applause]
unless a very sleepy guy got in and he
decided to quadruple everybody's taxes
then you can forget
he's a sleepy gun did you see he did a
lid
this morning again do you know what a
lid is
a lid is when you put out word you're
not going to be campaigning today
so he does a lid all the time i'm
working my ass off i'm in texas
i'm in ohio
[Applause]
thank you thank you but he puts a lid on
so a lid i didn't know what the hell it
was i've only been doing this for three
and a half years right so
but a lid is you know you're not gonna
go out today you're gonna stay in your
apartment or
let's put it this way in his basement so
early in the morning
he's put a lid on that means nothing for
today i guess they do that for the press
the fake news goes home and they say how
great he is as a candidate
they go home and they say he's a great
candidate but he put another litter did
many lids so he did a lid today
early in the morning that he won't be
working today and
i don't know i'm working so hard maybe
he's right think of it
supposing he never campaigns and he wins
you know how badly i'm gonna feel
i'm working hard and you gotta work hard
and you know what i said it today
we cannot have a low energy
individual as our president we can
and he's the lowest energy individual
i've ever seen
i've ever seen so we'll see what happens
but uh he's
living up maybe he's going to be great
at the debate you know he's been doing
it
for 47 years somebody said oh he won't
do well at the debate i said i think
you're wrong he'll do fine he's going to
do fine
he'll give him a big shot or something
and he'll go out there
he'll have a lot of energy he'll have
energy he'll be like
superman for about 15 minutes biden's
plan
will crush florida my plan will crush
the virus and we're doing it we're
rounding the turf
we're rounding the turn under my
leadership
prosperity will surge normal life oh i
love normal life we want to get back to
normal life
we'll fully resume the florida tourism
and hospitality industries will reach
record highs that's what's going to
happen you see it
and next year will be one of the
greatest years we are going to have
i'm telling you mark it down and if i'm
wrong you'll say i was wrong i'd say
sorry about that but
uh we're gonna have a great year we're
gonna have a great everything our
country is doing great our military has
never been stronger
we've taken out so many bad ones and
hopefully it's so strong that we'll
never have to use it
you understand that you want to make it
so strong we've never had
weapons like this no no country in the
world
ever possessed the power the weaponry
what we have is so incredible nobody's
ever possessed it before
not russia not china not anybody
we're the envy of the world hope to god
we never have to use them that's all i
can tell you this election
[Applause]
is about jobs and by the way speaking of
jobs it's all made in the usa everything
we have
and this lecture is also about
law and order you know they said oh
don't say law and order that's too
that's too tough a term they say sir say
law and order very lightly and then say
and safety
and liberty and this and i said no no
it's about
law and order we have to have law and
order right
and these democrat-run states are a
disaster
they're a disaster you look at what's
happening all over the country and
many of them look at portland how bad is
that i mean how bad is that
and i will say uh last night in kentucky
i spoke to the governor he's a democrat
with a great talk
and he pulled out his national guard and
he's doing it good and i give him credit
i give him credit but mostly they don't
want to do that i say
let us send the national guard i did it
in remember
minnesota we're going to win minnesota
so i did it in minneapolis
minnesota they were having a hard time
and took a little long a little longer
than we wanted but we got the okay to
get in we
solved that problem in about 25 minutes
i think it took
they formed the line that was the hard
part the easy part was just walking
straight ahead they never flinched
they were not socially distanced they
were right next to each other
they had 250 000 a piece uniforms they
had more stuff on their head i'm trying
to figure out what is it that computers
had
infrared goggles they had everything and
they walked forward with their canisters
of tear gas and pepper spray
and it was remember the cnn reporter he
went down he got hit on the knee with a
can
what yeah that's right he got hit he
said i'm down i'm down
he was down still i felt badly for him
though
he went down ali velchi remember he was
standing
and he was saying this is a friendly
protest
it's wonderful to see the lovely people
that are here you know that he's ducking
and behind him the entire city was
burning down do you remember
the entire city why are they doing that
what's the purpose of it i don't get it
i don't get it but no he got hit on the
knee with the canister of tear gas
they say it hurts
and that's only going 52 miles an hour a
bullet goes about 2 000 miles an hour
but they say it hurts but they cleaned
out that city
in a half an hour they had no problem
minneapolis that's one of the reasons
i'm going to
when another reason would be elaine omar
that's a reason omar
we're going to win because of omar
that's a beauty that's really she's
great
she's great she loves our country very
much
she has a total disrespect for our
country
and uh i think she has hatred for our
country but
uh i would say omar is a big reason that
we're gonna win they're not too fond of
her in minnesota
i'll always fight for the right of all
citizens to live in security and peace
so we have
law and order joe biden is weak as hell
he surrendered his party to flag burners
rioters and anti-police radicals
the democrat party's war on police you
know
a lot of people say cops i never liked
the word you know my father sit down
please come on we'll be here for a while
we have nothing else to do i have
nothing else to do except run a country
and the hardest part about running the
country is dealing with crazy democrats
you know um we're working on stimulus
for people because it's
it's not their fault it was china's
fault that we can't get nancy pelosi to
approve it
she wants to wait till after the
election i said people want their money
now
not going to have any impact from that
standpoint people want their money now
the democrat party's war on cops
is putting the lives of innocent police
officers in danger
but my father had great respect always
had great respect for law enforcement
for the police
and one time i said dad the cops are out
there look at that they look great
and he says never use the word cops it's
police
that's the kind of respect he had he
thought i don't want to
you know right look i have a couple of
pretty rough looking guys
no it's true so i always find it a
little hard you know i just left an
impression this police
he thought it was slang and i don't
think they mind i don't think
how many we got a lot of them here does
anybody mind the term cops
who's are here that's a police man or
woman
policeman do they mind
a lot of them a lot of them
do they mind that term cops no
they just want respect and they just
want to be allowed to do their job
properly as nobody can do it do you
agree with that
that's what i say all right now start
calling them cops he said we don't
just respect us and let us do our job
earlier this month
two sheriffs deputies were ambushed at
close range in los angeles california i
called them both
and they're okay but they were hit they
were hit bad last night as you know two
police officers were shot
in louisville kentucky every year dozens
of courageous police officers
lay down their lives for people that
they never met
people that they don't know people they
never saw in most cases right
they lay down their lives from people
they never met they're incredible
law enforcement let's give them a hand
[Applause]
please
thank you very much i tell them all the
time you know we have endorsements from
all of them but
i tell them all the time you have no
idea how much you love you know they
don't hear it because they watch the
fake news at night and
you don't get the you don't get the
truth that's a lot of guys that's a lot
of people back there
that's a lot of fakers back look at all
those red lights
the red light means you're on live you
know the problem with being on live
you're making a little bit of a mistake
and they say this was a horrible
all right thank you that's enough that's
enough of that
that's very dishonest it's a shame
really does hurt our country it's so
fake
they don't show the protesters they
don't show it you know when you think
that
like cities are burning down and
storefronts are being exploded people
are being killed
they would have you believe there's
nothing happening it's the most
incredible thing
i don't even understand why no matter
where your philosophy is no matter where
you stand
why wouldn't you want to show the facts
show what's happening and then we fix it
the republican cities don't have trouble
the republican states they don't have
trouble
you got it you go to different states i
don't know
they find it you know some of these
governors friends of mine
and they're friends on both sides but
republican governors red states they
look like
how is a thing like this possible
because they have law and order
they have law and order for this i mean
that's what it is
for the entire summer joe biden was
silent
as his far left supporters assaulted
police officers
harassed innocent americans and set fire
to buildings
they were rioters they were looters they
were anarchists
he called them peaceful protesters he
said they're peaceful protesters
[Music]
joe they're not peaceful now maybe he
believe he may believe it i mean
honestly they may say they're peaceful
okay i'll
say their peace i think he believes it i
actually do
it's the other ones that you have to
worry about because they call the shots
not him he's called for
the ridiculous cutting of police funding
abolishing cash bail if you can believe
that
and the closing of our prisons they want
to close our prisons that's a good idea
he even described law enforcement as the
enemy he said law enforcement is the
enemy
now you know i am i assume i'll ask the
fake news has he taken it back by
yourself because he's taken
everything back he's taken anti-fracking
back
he's taken pretty much everything back
but remember it's the first thing
they say that's what they stick with
biden's anti-police crusade
must stop as president i will always
stand with the heroes
of law enforcement that's why we're here
and i was honored to receive the
endorsement of 48 sheriffs right here in
florida
three weeks ago
and all over the country law enforcement
from texas
arizona ohio oklahoma michigan wisconsin
pennsylvania new york's finest endorsed
me they've never endorsed the
presidential campaign
the national troopers coalition chicago
how about that chicago police they
endorsed me chicago
and all the major law enforcement
organizations all across
they go back home to mommy they say
mommy i'm sorry
i'm sorry you know the incredible thing
about that
i didn't hear anything except our crowd
no they have no voice they're screaming
at the top of their lungs but their
lungs are very small
and i didn't hear all of a sudden you
hear whoa like this right here
that's true if people if you wouldn't
recognize them we wouldn't even know
they're here
now tomorrow the headline is so you had
one young protester
the headline will be tomorrow trump's
rally broken up by protests
one very young
girl she's a girl am i allowed to say
girl she looks like she's like
about 16 years old how the hell is that
happen
250 generals and military leaders also
hundreds and hundreds of military
spouses
have given their complete and total
endorsement to our campaign
to uphold the laws of our land
and to uphold our constitution as
written on saturday i will be
announcing my nominee to the united
states supreme court
[Music]
it's true it's gonna be a big deal we're
doing it on the
we're doing it at the white house the
rose garden of the white house
unless it's raining in which case we'll
still do it there that's okay
it's beautiful the white house so
beautiful we love the white house right
outside the oval office
and you know they don't want us to do it
the democrats say
you shouldn't do it why
we have a lot of time let me ask you the
one simple question
if it was them instead of us do you
think they do it
i think so now this will be a very
talented person it will be
a woman i'm sorry man it will be a woman
[Applause]
all right ready who would rather see
a man oh that's trouble
try it again who would rather see a man
that's not good who would rather see a
woman
i think it would be really i think it
would take tremendous courage
i don't care how great the man is ladies
and gentlemen i'd like to tell you
that jim fitzgerald
and then you would see a lot of very
unhappy faces right
my opponent refuses to release
his list of potential justices because
they will be hand-picked by extremists
like representative alexandria
ocasio-cortez
[Applause]
sometimes known as aoc plus three right
as
and one of the three i think is omar
right but they'll pick
the first so if biden does that if he
puts an extremist
into that position he loses everything
that's like
normal and if he does the other way he
loses the left
so he doesn't want to give a left i'd
love to have him put up a list i'd like
to see what that
i could see what that list would be i
could already tell you the people on
that list it would not be good it would
not be pretty you would not be happy
that would be the end if given power
biden and his supporters would pack the
court you know they're talking about
packing the court
because we have won races we have one
uh i'll tell you what so this will be my
third and we're in great shape you see
the
do you see what's going on with the
republican party how unified the
republican party is
right now we're unified it's a beautiful
thing to say thank you mitt
thank you appreciate it even mitzonborg
even mitsumbor no it's uh it's a good
thing to see
having a unified party of course when
they did the impeachment hoax
we had 197 to nothing in the house
and 52 and a half to a half that was bit
but that's okay i'm no longer angry at
[ __ ] because he's being very nice on
the supreme court he's doing
he's doing the right thing i just want
him to do the right thing
but they want to pack the court you know
that means they want to put on a lot of
justices these are things that are just
horrible
i guess we could do that too right we
could do that today
but remember it was harry reid that made
this all possible
you know they're angry at us listen
chuck cryon chuck you know what crying
chuck is
chuck every time you complain remember
it was harry reid
your person in charge he had your job
before
it was harry reid who made this all
possible thank you very much harry i
hope you're enjoying your evening
they blame us harry reid gave us the
power nuclear option
thank you harry very much but he wants
to pack the court supreme court
with radicals who will terminate the
second amendment
confiscate your firearms eliminate the
right to self-defense strike
under god from the pledge of allegiance
and all other places
[Music]
tear down crosses from public spaces
and force taxpayers to fund extreme
late
term abortion
these far left justices would release
violent criminals shield foreign
terrorists
impose sanctuary cities and declare
the death penalty totally
unconstitutional
hey it will be totally unconstitutional
they want to declare it unconstitutional
for even
the most depraved mass murderers
and it's a tough thing it's a tough
thing they came to my office today at
the death penalty
for clemency i said what was the crime
the crime was so horrible that i won't
tell you what it was but it's been going
on for 21 years or so
the crime was so horrible that this
person committed that i said look i just
can't talk about it it was so
it was so horrible and that's usually
the case
usually the case like the boston bomber
and by the way they want to give votes
to prisoners people in prison they want
to give us
so we immediately said remember bernie
crazy bernie
bernie is i'll tell you one thing about
him
he's the greatest loser i've ever seen
no i mean that in a respectful way
because what they did to him with
hillary was bad but this time was even
worse
elizabeth pocahontas warren would have
left the campaign
one day before super tuesday bernie with
her
ideology basically because she's a
radical left
and she was really fresh to him but she
was really fresh
how bad was elizabeth warren
to joe biden there's only one person
that was worse who was worse
kamala i said he'll never this shows you
my great
instinct my great knowledge of politics
i said
he will never pick kamala because no
human being has been treated worse but
than anybody
then kamala remember she called him a
racist
she called him xenophobic
she called him all sorts of things she
called him
things that were so bad i can't say him
i can't say him
but she called him a lot of things i
said well she's out and then he picks
her
you always pick people going up not
going down in the polls you know if i
were going to pick and by the way how
good is mike pence is he great
okay he's a rock he's a solid guy
and he's a great guy and a great vice
president and he works so hard he's all
over the place he's in michigan he's and
he's everywhere where'd you go today
mike i went to michigan
north carolina south carolina
i went to wisconsin
the guy i tell you what he's an
incredible guy and he's a great guy and
he loves the people of this country he
loves our country
you cannot do better than mike pence
if you want to save america you must get
out
and vote
in just three and a half years we've
secured our borders
rebuilt the awesome power of the u.s
military
obliterated isis caliphate 100 percent
fixed our disastrous trade deals and
they were a disaster i read some of them
they i said
who agrees to this stuff stupid people
agreed to it
and brought jobs back home to america
and we brought them back
you had the greatest year you've ever
had last year
the greatest year you've ever had
under 16 years of presidents obama and
bush
household income rose only 2
945 okay
that's over a course of 16 years close
to 3 000 right
in three years and including energy
because look at the saving how are you
doing at the gas pump
not so bad right have you ever seen that
do you ever think that was going to
happen
in three years so that was less than 3
000 over 16. in three years you went up
ten thousand dollars including
energy
we lifted 6.6 million people out of
poverty the largest poverty reduction
in the first three years of any
president in the history of our country
we built the greatest economy in the
history of the world not only here
anywhere
we were beating everybody you know for
years i heard that china
in 2019 was going to overtake us right
that didn't happen
and they released the plague but that
didn't happen and it's still not
happening with the plague because they
got hit hard themselves
i wonder if they understood that they
were going to get hit too right
but the plague came here they could have
stopped it they could have stopped it
from going all over the world 188
countries
all over the world including europe and
the united states
we've added a record 10.6 million jobs
in the last four months including 3.3
million jobs
for hispanic americans
that's a record both numbers
when the plague arrived from china we
launched the largest
national mobilization since world war ii
we pioneered life-saving therapies
reducing the fatality rate
85 since april you see what's happening
europe has almost a 50 percent greater
excess mortality rate
than the united states and now you see
they're being hit very hard the fake
news was saying well i don't know if
you've done as well
as europe i said we did better than
europe and now europe is exploding again
unfortunately i don't want that to
happen but they don't want to talk about
that because that's not good for their
narrative
our early and aggressive action saved
many millions of lives
through operation warp speed we
developed and distribute a vaccine we
will have a vaccine
so soon you won't even believe it
although they're trying to do a little
bit of a political hit
let's let's delay it just a little bit
you notice that let's delay the vaccine
just a little bit but we have three
great companies and then
others also johnson and johnson
right fisa moderna
great companies all of them great
companies and they're right there
they're way advanced way advancer in the
final steps
i took historic action to get critical
relief for
american workers through our paycheck
protection program we save
3.2 million florida jobs
[Applause]
we're launching a historic effort to
bring our medical supply chains
back home where they belong
in 1996 joe biden voted to obliterate
puerto rico's thriving
pharmaceutical industry i am reversing
that
and we're going back so that puerto rico
can get its pharmaceutical industry
back and they're going gonna have it
back soon
that was joe biden that did that and
then they'll vote because automatically
how do they vote for a democrat what's
the purpose
he's the one that did it he's the one
look what he did how devastated look at
what he did to
our african-american community and
people don't want to talk about it but
what he did was devastating
devastating he's not good for he's not
good for anyone let's face it
last week i also announced an additional
13 billion dollars that goes to disaster
relief for puerto rico they got hit hard
i hope they remember that that was given
by trump
not by the democrats our hearts are also
with the communities in the panhandle i
love the panhandle
ron will tell you
i'll tell you you're great governor and
he's doing a great job he called up he
said the pan handles it sir
they love you in the pan i think i've
been about 99.9 percent
in the panhandle but we took care of
we took care of the panhellen remember
hurricane sally that was not good but we
took care of it
ron came into my office he'd say sir we
need more money i said how much he gave
me a number you don't even want to
believe
i said you got to run don't come back
ron he comes back about three days later
sir
we need more money but that's
i guess a good governor that's what a
good governor does right
that's what a good governor does
i approve the major disaster declaration
for the state of florida last night
and we will be with you every step of
the way every step you're there
we're there so fast we sometimes you
know other presidents took a long time
to approve them
i approve them before the storms hit
shore
because we know what's going to happen
we took care of florida
on november 3rd florida will decide
whether we end the pandemic and return
to record prosperity or whether we allow
joe biden
to kill the recovery delay the vaccine
impose a four trillion dollar tax hike
ban american energy which he wants to do
destroy the suburbs he's going to
destroy the suburbs
give free health care to illegal aliens
which means millions and millions of
people are going to pour into our
country
and indoctrinate your children with
poisonous anti-american lies in their
class and their story
to combat the toxic left-wing propaganda
in our schools
i announced something last week that was
very popular
that we're launching a new pro-american
lesson plan for students called
1776 commissions
we'll teach our children the truth about
america that we are the most exceptional
nation on the face of the earth
and you haven't seen anything yet you
see what we're doing
i've also issued an executive order to
prohibit the teaching of
critical race theory in the federal
government
[Applause]
that hateful marxist doctrine paints
america
as a wicked nation seeks to divide
everyone by race rewrites american
history
and teaches people to be ashamed of
themselves and be ashamed
of their country that's not happening
anymore we fired
so many of these wise guys we had one
getting
350 000 a year teaching our military
this
stuff and he said what happened we said
you're fired get out
done many people
no it's become it's become a cancer it's
like a cancer
but many many people gone they're all
gone
and if they're not let us know and we'll
let them go
but we have to unite together as one
proud american family that's what we are
we are joined tonight by some incredible
warriors some incredible people one of
them that i'm most proud of is
a man that came to this state and what a
job he's done
your great governor ron desantis
he's doing a great job ron is doing a
great job ron how are we doing in the
election how are we doing on november
3rd ron
okay he says we better do good
well he uh won a great primer and then
he beat a man that they said had a good
future i'm not thinking his future's
looking too good right
how's this future i don't think it's too
good right now ron was great tough and
strong and he didn't choke under
pressure that's for sure
but much more important than ron is the
first lady of florida
casey vicente
the mayor of jacksonville a really good
guy i got him to
really he wanted to do it so bad we
wanted to have our
republican national convention right
here in jacksonville
but the timing was a little bit bad we
got hit a little bit with uh kovit as
they say we got hit a little bit with
the china virus
but i'll tell you what lenny curry was
absolutely fantastic
your mayor lenny curry
all right you ready some of the greatest
toughest
warriors you'll ever meet during the
impeachment hoax they said this is the
biggest
pilot crap you've ever seen
i'm the only guy in history that got
impeached
for an absolutely perfect conversation
it was perfect we said it around
everyone said what's wrong with this
we sent it to the justice department
please check this thank goodness we had
people that were taking it down right
exact notes great patriots they took it
down
two of them and it was perfect we sent
it to the justice department
please examine this conversation
we'd like to know what you think they
called back they said uh
okay listen now what exactly are you
looking for here
you know these guys are used to looking
at killings and drug dealers
they're saying uh explain to us what are
you looking for we don't see anything
you know
this was the greatest hoax and today by
the way you see what happened
they caught them they've got them called
they got them called we'll talk about it
in a second
they caught them they now find out that
trump was a hundred percent truthful
it was a hoax they got them cold it was
just announced
dan scavino just said it's the biggest
it's the hottest thing on the internet
they got them cold we'll talk about it
in a second but these warriors
when i needed warriors i had a
representative matt gates
[Applause]
i'm matt what a great guy
what a guy big future thank you man what
a warrior
thank you but he's very shy on
television right i know this
he's great thank you matt ted yoho
ted ted
where is that
great job now uh
you know a man that is
in charge of all spying he was so good
that matt and ron and ted
and mike waltz and a lot of people came
to see me mike
another great one thank you mike
is john rutherford here where is he
where
what a good job john thank you thank you
for the help thank you joe
but mike waltz has been so great and
candidate for congress kat
kammack pat
[Applause]
so kat was in the oval office yesterday
right
and uh i said how are you doing sir i'm
up 42
i said 42 what 42 points that was a big
trump district right
you're not in any real trouble that's uh
for sure she's got that was a great that
was a great win you had
she'll be with us a long time a long
time i want to
i really appreciate it and
we also have some others that are
running for different offices in the
republican party
and we love the republican party they
have been incredible
they have been incredible we also have
some of our
really unbelievable undercover
operatives and if you don't mind i won't
introduce them
all right i don't think we're going to
introduce them i want to so badly
i want to have them stand up bring them
up here i want to hug them and kiss them
which i'm not allowed to do because of
social distance
but somehow they may lose some
effectiveness if i introduce them
so they're in the crowd i saw two of
them and i won't bother but they are
great great champions of our country
thank you thank you
and also here is a woman who was so
i mean she was tough she was in charge
of
a great state of michigan and she kept
asking me come back you're going to win
everyone said you know republicans
hadn't won
michigan in many decades and i felt i
should because i was bringing back
and i was doing so much for the business
and jobs and bringing
people back and recommending and telling
them you're losing your
business to mexico canada and they gave
me 12 years ago they gave me the man of
the year in michigan and i
made this crazy speech that i said
you're losing all your jobs to mexico
and all of a sudden i'm running for
office and a woman who handled it was
unbelievable she'd say to me sir would
you please come and make a speech i said
who are you
my name is ronna mcdaniel i'm in charge
of michigan where's rob
[Music]
she said my name is ronna mcdaniel i'm
in charge of michigan
i said i hear we don't have a chance we
should win michigan but i hear
you're going to win it if you come here
so i went and made a speech said i want
to make another speech since you'd call
again
and again i couldn't take it
and then i said look i'll do one more
she wanted me to do one more she said
i'm telling you you're gonna win
do one more this is two weeks left
and i said all right this is it though
this is it you know i've devoted a lot
of time to michigan and everyone says
you can't win by the way
just got a poll with three points up in
michigan
she said sir that she used to call me mr
trump i wasn't president yet
she said sir please uh just this one
time this is it three
three weeks out i said all right this is
it
can't do anymore i gotta go to a lot of
states that's it this is it so i promise
so i did it then the night before the
election she said sir you're going to
win michigan but you got to make one
more stop i set you down
and i made it on election day i arrived
at 12 15 in the now morning that was now
election day right
i started speaking at one o'clock in the
morning on
election day my wife said are you crazy
we had 32 000 people
and the reason i went she wanted us
there but we found out that crooked
hillary clinton
barack hussein obama and mrs obama
and bill clinton were traveling to
michigan unexpectedly
because as bill clinton told them three
months ago you're going to have trouble
with trump in michigan
they don't want to listen to him you
know they said oh well
because he's a natural politician and he
said you're going to have trouble in
wisconsin too and be careful of
minnesota
this was clinton remember they were
laughing they thought he was very funny
but they knew they were in trouble so
they flew there they had 500 people
i went there and i started speaking at
one in the morning with 32
000 people in grand rapids
in grand rapids
and i said it's like this i said
we're not going to lose this state you
can't lose when you have a cut you can't
lose you know you can look at a crowd i
can look at this graph
i can see look at it as far as the eye
can see as far as the eye can see
i'd leave here i say we're not losing
florida i can tell you that you can tell
you can feel it
you can feel it you have an instinct
we're joined as well by a group of
incredible supporters who have recently
walked away from the
democrat party they walked away from the
democrats
they just registered as republicans
thank you thank you
and they're going to be voting for us
they're just a whole big group of people
and i thank you and you're all over the
place
thank you thank you they know
it's called they're smart and they have
common sense
we've spent the last four years
reversing the
terrible damage joe biden inflicted over
the last
47 years together we've taken on
a corrupt and broken system that's been
throwing everything at us from the very
beginning and remember this and i say it
all the time
i've done more in 47 months than joe
biden's done
in 47 years
that's true
but today a trove of text messages was
released from the fbi agents
involved in the russia witch hunt did
you you had to see this this is what i
was talking about before
the headline from the federalist reads
trump was right explosive new fbi texts
detail internal fuhrer over handling of
the
crossfire hurricane investigation that
was the name
we caught him we had him before this but
this is like
remember the insurance policy darling
darling oh i love you so much sarla
she's going to win isn't she yes
100 million to one that's not good odds
for me
it might not have been great but they
were a lot better than that 100 million
to one lisa
i love you so much but if for some
reason
she doesn't win we have an insurance
policy that's what we've been living
through their insurance policy
you can't be any more obvious than that
these people are scum they were trying
to do
[Applause]
a coup who would think
and we caught them before that we caught
them spying on our nation
and they've gotten caught let's see what
happens with them now but this was a big
day
this was a big day never forget
they are coming after me because i am
fighting for you with a lot of truth
that
for decades our politicians spent
trillions of dollars
rebuilding foreign nations fighting
foreign wars
and defending foreign borders but now we
are finally protecting our nation
rebuilding our cities
and we are bringing our jobs our
factories and our troops
back home to the usa
joe biden championed every globalist
betrayal of america for 47 years
he was a cheerleader for nafta the worst
trade deal ever made
emptied out your fact and he was a
cheerleader for china's
entry into the world trade organization
i took the toughest ever action to stand
up to china's rampant theft
of american jobs and i proudly signed a
historic executive order making an
official government policy to
buy american and hire americans
by the way you ever see this guy he's
using my slogan he's using my slogans
i saw him the other day it's like buy
america and i said i've been saying that
for five years
right he's using my he has no clue
you got to come up with your own slogan
show
we invested 2.5 trillion dollars in the
u.s military and launched
the first new branch of u.s armed forces
in nearly 75 years after the air force
the space force
[Applause]
we passed va choice and va
accountability nobody thought that could
happen
we have a 91 approval rating in the
va right 91 approval rate
highest in history highest average you
ever see i don't want to say this to
them because they'll find a vet
is there an unhappy vet someplace 91
approval remember we used to always
watch every night you see things on the
news about how
badly the vets are treated now we have a
91
approval rating my guys are doing a
great job and today i can announce that
the va is approving a new 46 million
dollar lease for a brand new veterans
health care clinic
in north jacksonville
we killed the founder and leader of isis
al-baghdadi
we took out the world's number one
terrorists all over the world number one
the mass murder of american troops and
many others
kasim solamini is dead
look him out he deserved to be taken out
we withdrew
from the last administration's
disastrous
iran nuclear deal 150 billion dollars
you know what he got for nothing 1.8
billion in cash you got nothing
nothing i kept my promise recognized the
true capital of israel
and opened the american embassy in
jerusalem
[Applause]
i also recognize israeli sovereignty
over the golan heights
and instead of endless war we are
forging peace in the middle east you saw
what
is happening
in fact i was nominated for two nobel
peace prizes last week
you know the story you know this thing
and i told our great first lady i said
first lady i was
nominated for the nobel peace prize
i'm going to come home early i'm going
to watch it on nbc news which is one of
the biggest
scam jobs i've ever seen nbc probably
worse than siena
nbc but we're going to watch it we're
going to watch the evening news
so we'll watch second place nbc you know
it is at second place they spent
all this money on pr and then i hit them
hard
but they are bad i said first lady when
you see it nobel peace prize
this will definitely be the biggest
thing all right
ladies and gentlemen nbc they start off
with
you they said you you had some heavy
rain they started off with something
else something else something else
something else
nowadays almost already said first lady
they're not mentioning the nobel peace
prize
this is very embarrassing but then it
was okay because
two days later i got nominated again
that was for israel
i got nominated again
and i remember when o'brian remember
when obama got
he said ladies and gentlemen barack
hussein obama has just been nominated
for the nobel peace prize
so what happened so what happened i said
first lady i just got nominated again
this time for
kosovo serbia they're not killing each
other anymore i stopped it
it's totally different the first was
israel
right bahrain uae this one was
kosovo totally different i don't know if
that's ever happened before i said first
lady let's give it another shot
we watched the news never even mentioned
when barack obama got his nobel prize
like
immediately after he got elected they
asked him why did you get it he had no
clue
nobody knew nobody knew and it was a big
story breaking news we have breaking
news i didn't have breaking news when i
got it but that's why
we understand the press we understand
them very well they're fake
the last administration
made a pathetic one-sided deal with a
castro dictatorship
that betrayed the cuban people and
enriched the communist regime
my opponent stands with socialists and
communists i stand with
the proud people of cuba nicaragua
venezuela
in their righteous struggle for freedom
and you're going to win it very soon
you're going to win that very soon the
last administration
also negotiated the terrible obama
biden santos deal with colombian drug
cartels
they surrendered the narco terrorists
they surrendered to them
and they caused illicit drug production
to soar
under my administration we worked with
our
colombian partners to launch a historic
rival operation against the drug
traffickers
and since april we have seized or
disrupted
227 metric tons of poisonous
narcotics nobody has ever done anything
like it
joe biden opposed the mission to take
out osama bin laden
he opposed killing solomani he voted for
the iraq war he backed the disastrous
iran nuclear deal
and he cheered for the rise of china
as a positive development for our
country i don't think so
that was a disaster now biden's put
forward the most dangerous and extreme
platform of any major party nominee in
history
the bad news is he doesn't even know
what the hell it is
the biden plan would destroy social
security and destroy
protections for pre-existing conditions
it will drain your medicare by giving
free health care to
illegal immigrants that will come over
to this country by the millions
when they see this and virtually all
immigration enforcement and oppose
totally open borders he would terminate
our travel bans
on jihadist regions remember i got that
approved
they kept saying oh he lost he lost he
lost and then i wanted the supreme court
we have a travel ban guess what
and increased refugee admissions by over
700 opening the floodgates to
radical islamic terrorism
he wants to ban school choice and ban
charter schools which
are absolutely imperative for our
children
in a second term i will provide school
choice to every parent in america
a vote for republicans
[Applause]
is a vote for safe communities great
jobs and a limitless future
for all americans and in conclusion
over the next four years we will make
america into the manufacturing
superpower of the world
and we will end our reliance on china
once and for all
[Applause]
we will make our medical supplies right
here in the united states
we will hire more police increased
penalties for assaults from law
enforcement
and we will ban deadly sanctuary cities
we will defend the dignity of work and
the sanctity of life
we will uphold religious liberty free
speech
and the right to keep and bear arms
second amendment
we will strike down terrorists who
threaten our citizens
and we will keep out of america of our
great country
we will stay away from those ridiculous
endless foreign wars they never end
endless foreign they're all coming
home they're all coming home we will
maintain america's unrivaled military
might
and we will ensure peace through
strength and nobody has strength like we
have strength peace through strength
we will end surprise medical bills
require price transparency and further
reduce health insurance premiums and the
cost of
prescription drugs they're going to be
coming down by
30 40 50 60 70
favored nations favorite nations laws
we'll be paying as low as anybody in the
world favorite nations nobody had the
guts to do it
and they are spending a lot of money on
ads against me right now those that big
pharma
they are spending a lot of money we will
strongly protect
medicare and social security and we will
always protect patients with
pre-existing conditions
america will land the first woman on the
moon and the united states will be the
first nation to land an
astronaut on mars
uh
thank you that's really nice
i had such a nice life before doing this
but no administration has ever done
in the first three and a half years not
even close what we've done
and that's very gratifying i want to
tell you that
[Applause]
and thank you very much we will stop the
radical indoctrination of our students
and restore patriotic education to our
schools
we will teach our children to love our
country honor our history
and always respect our great american
[Applause]
flag
and we will live by the timeless words
of our national motto
in god we trust
for years you had a president who
apologized for america
now you have a president who is standing
up for america and standing up
for the great people of florida
so get your friends get your family get
your neighbors
get your co-workers and get out and vote
we have to win this election most
important election we've ever had
early voting has already begun don't
wait
vote it's safe go out and vote
i hear we're doing very well by the way
that's what the word is uh we'll see
we'll see but i hear we're doing very
well
from tampa to tallahassee
from orlando to miami from pensacola
to right here in jacksonville
we stand on the shoulders of florida
patriots who gave their blood sweat and
tears for this beloved nation
we inherit the legacy of american heroes
who cross the oceans
blaze the trails settled the continent
tamed the wilderness dug out the panama
canal
laid down the railroads raised up the
skyscrapers
won two world wars defeated fascism and
communism
and from here in this beautiful
beautiful
state this sun-drenched state of florida
we launched american astronauts to the
moon
we made america into the single greatest
nation in the history of the world
and the best is yet to come
[Applause]
proud citizens like you helped build
this country
and together we are taking back our
country we are returning the power
to you the american people
[Applause]
with your help your devotion your drive
we are going to keep on working we are
going to keep on fighting
and we are going to keep on winning
winning
winning
[Applause]
we are one movement one people
one family and one glorious nation under
god
and together with the incredible people
of florida
we will make america wealthy again
we will make america strong again
we will make america proud again
we will make america safe again
and we will make america
great again thank you florida thank you
[Music]
florida
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's fun to stay at the
[Applause]
[Music]
it's hard to
[Music]
you can do whatever you feel
[Music]
but you've got to know this
one thing no man does it all by himself
put your pride on the shelf and just go
down
to the ymca i'm sure hey
today
it's fun to stay involved
[Music]
you can hang out with all of our boys
[Music]
someone came up to me and said the man
take a walk up the street it's a place
there
called the ymca they can't stop
your way
[Music]
my joy
[Music]
feel down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what do you want to be
[Music]
blue
[Music]
blue jean baby
[Music]
[Music]
you must have seen her
dancing in the sand
now she's in me
always with me
tiny dancing in my hand
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
looking on she sings the songs
the word she knows
[Music]
[Music]
and you can hear me
when i say it softly
[Music]
slowly
[Music]
and she's so bland
[Music]
[Music]
dancing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she's so blind
[Music]
today
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you must see them
[Music]
me
tiny bits in my hand
[Music]
you can hear me
[Music]